morning Sophie's away this week and
since Skye couldn't stretch to chat GPT
you have the next best thing I'm Trevor
Phillips
they told me to be a Dos this week it's
half term nothing much going on they
lied the prime minister went to Munich
yesterday ahead of what looks like a
Russian offensive and ticked off an
audience of world leaders telling them
that they need to double down in their
military backing for Ukraine
he was a bit less forthright in Belfast
selling what might be a post-brexit
trade deal to a notoriously tough crowd
Northern Ireland Democratic unionist
Party
this morning we learned that Boris
Johnson doesn't think much of the sunac
plan and doesn't much like the agreement
though he hasn't seen it yet
labor says it could back a deal
kierstama probably reckons he can afford
to be generous when you're 25 points
ahead in the polls you've eliminated
Troublesome internal opposition and
Nicholas sturgeon surrendering the
spotlight it pays to look statesmanlike
and then to cap it all there's a budget
looming
brace yourselves
in just a moment we'll hear from the
leader of the House of Commons Penny
Morton
and for labor the party's Shadow Home
Secretary Yvette Cooper
with a deal over the Northern Ireland
protocol in site we'll try to find out
how it might be received by eurosceptic
conservatives with their longtime
figurehead and former business secretary
Jacob Reese smog
we'll also speak to the former Northern
Ireland secretary Peter now Lord
mandelson who can give us an insight
into how they may be thinking in
Brussels given his time as an EU trade
commissioner there
and we'll get a sense of the mood in
Belfast this weekend from the leader of
the Cross Community Alliance party Naomi
long
[Music]
let's start this morning hearing from
the government a few moments ago I spoke
to the leader of the House of Commons
pennymordant
good morning I'd like to start with the
awful story of Nicola bully who's been
missing now for more than three weeks
both the Home Secretary and the Prime
Minister have expressed concern about
the handling of the investigation do you
share that concern
I can't imagine what this must have been
like for her family it's bad enough if a
member of our family goes goes missing
but to have all this additional uh drama
and distraction from the most important
thing which is to find out what has
happened uh to her
um my thoughts are are with them I think
the Prime Minister and the Home
Secretary have been right to express
concerns about that but but really the
priority here has been what it always
should have been which is to find her
okay
let's talk about the political news and
of course top story today is going to be
Northern Ireland the Prime Minister says
that we may be close to a deal but we're
not there yet what are the obstacles
that remain to an agreement that would
allow Stormwind to reassemble and
possibly allow you not to have to pursue
the Northern Ireland protocol bill well
look there are encouraging signs but the
Prime Minister has said that there is
still hard work to be done and everyone
will be pulling together to ensure that
we're giving that deal the best chance
possible what matters here and the prime
minister is very focused on this is what
the people of Northern Ireland think
about this deal this has to be
acceptable to all communities in
Northern Ireland and the EU is aware of
that so I I wish them well I think it
would be great if we can arrive at that
point but that's the test it's not what
I or any other member of the commons
thinks it's the people of Northern
Ireland but how close is close is it
days or are we weeks away months what do
you think look I think I think good
progress has been made but clearly there
is still more to be done both both sides
have been the negotiations have said
we're not there yet but those
negotiations are still progressing and
uh and there are there are optimistic
signs all right well look um people can
be helpful and they can be that's
helpful and
um let's talk about the various parties
to this summon your own party say that
the European court of justice should
play no part for example in settling
disputes between Britain and the EU on
trade
um can you envisage any agreement in
which the ecj plays no part at all
being acceptable to the EU look I'm not
party to the negotiations I'm not cited
on the detail but what I can tell you is
that unless this deal is satisfactory to
to all communities in Northern Ireland
it won't be possible it's not going to
work but it's also going to be
satisfactory to the EU hasn't it it has
but the I mean the dups tests that they
have referred to are not a random wish
list they are promises that we have made
to the to the people of Northern Ireland
that that is the the bar that this deal
has to has to get over and uh and I know
that the prime minister is completely
focused on that uh
you're in danger of being a bit clear
here which is unusual the dp7 tests
involve no role for the ecj are you
saying that this can't happen
unless that test is met the prime
minister is focused on removing those
practical difficulties but he is also
been talking about the the Democratic
deficit he's been talking about ensuring
that the people of Northern Ireland
through their representatives are able
to have a say on any future uh
regulation that they might be subject to
these are important things it is very
tough it's tough stuff but that is what
the prime minister is focused on I've no
further detail on the on the
nitty-gritty of the of the negotiations
Trevor but I I think there are
encouraging signs but there is a lot
more to be done absence of detail
doesn't seem to have discourage
um some of your colleagues from having a
view including the former prime minister
who says or rather a source close to Mr
Johnson uh saying this morning that
it would be a great mistake to drop the
Northern Ireland protocol Bill the story
behind this is that apparently he thinks
that it's absolutely essential to make
sure that you have leverage that you
retain the ability to withdraw
unilaterally from um the the protocol
do you think it is possible to reach an
agreement that would satisfy that part
of your party
well look I think the the first thing to
say is and I think the Prime Minister
would acknowledge this we're only able
to be having these negotiations and
discussions because of what previous
administrations have done and the
command paper and the the Northern
Ireland protocol Bill have been helpful
to get us where we are today I think
that's that's the first thing and uh the
intervention by a source close to the
the previous prime minister is helpful
to remind the EU of that of that bill
and uh what this deal actually has to
deliver but I'll come back to it Trevor
it's not about me or any other Member of
Parliament it is about the communities
in Northern Ireland and getting this to
work for them that is our priority I
know it's your job to be diplomatic but
seriously you think that Boris Johnson's
intervention is helpful I think that all
parties want this to be a success they
want those very practical issues that
the people of Northern Ireland have been
grappling with and that are causing
unnecessary friction in our trading
Arrangements they they want the the
territorial Integrity of the United
Kingdom to be a certainty this is what
we all want it's difficult but we are
making progress and uh and I wish the
Prime Minister well but
forgive me I I understand what you're
trying to say that there needs to be a
consensus everybody needs to be generous
and so on but it's already clear that
for some members of your party and I'm
going to come to the dup in a moment
there are red lines uh John Redwood who
senior member of the party he represents
a particular strain of opinion has
tweeted this morning were to the effect
that the EU consultation with the
northern Isle assembly would still leave
Northern Ireland under EU control
these people are not going to come
quietly are they they're not going to be
as generous as you apparently are being
this morning
well it's again it's not about a winning
a vote in the in the Commons we we don't
know what the
um following procedures will will need
to be it all depends on what that uh
what that deal is and if we if we get to
a deal at all but uh I I think everyone
is uh is
agreeing with each other unless we have
every community in Northern Ireland
behind this deal it won't last and it
won't work that this is why this is
difficult
um but I think you know it's it's at
moments like this when when governments
and prime ministers are tested and the
prime minister is in absolutely clear
that the priority in this is the people
of Northern Ireland that that is what he
has in his mind uh and what his team
have in their minds when they're
negotiating all right well I'll give
this one last go what is Boris Johnson
actually up to
well
Boris is is being
is being says this is a completely
unhelpful uh intervention
um and I think as I say the Prime
Minister I think will acknowledge that
uh having the Northern Ireland protocol
Bill there having the the work uh that
the former prime minister did is has
helped us get where we are but it's
always been our preference to try and
have a negotiated settlement and and
that is what everyone is working to
there's still a lot to be done or
progress has been made all right let me
take you a word about the Northern
Ireland communities the Democratic units
party
has been pretty clear
I've put some of the points that they
share with members of your party to you
already
um
and come into the line
um Stormont is not going to reassemble
uh is the government ready to for
example resume direct rule if the
assembly simply just can't sit because
the dup won't accept a deal
so look we we have and we've we've done
this previously we we've had to step in
we we obviously want to make sure that
there's a there's a budget there we we
are the backstop for uh for for the
assembly that's that's always been the
case but but we want uh we want
government to be to be re-established in
in Northern Ireland that is that is what
we we want and uh
but you haven't been able to do it and
that's not necessarily your fault if if
Mr Donaldson and his colleagues Jeffrey
are beg your pardon Johnson and his
colleagues say we're not going to play
ball are you ready to resume direct rule
look there is there is obviously an
element of of local politics in all of
this but but fundamentally the the deal
that the prime minister is trying to uh
negotiate at the moment is is going to
be a key part of getting the assembly
stood up again that is why it is
absolutely critical that all parties
have confidence in the process and have
confidence with what is arrived at we we
don't know whether we're going to be
able to secure a deal or not but if we
do
um and it's a good one then that will
play a big part in uh in getting the
assembly re-established
you're obviously very hopeful and um the
late party says that um
actually they will support
a deal if it's one that for example
maintains uh the Integrity of the Good
Friday agreement
um
are you okay about that that you might
actually have to if you have to
introduce legislation and it possibly
might not do but if you do have to
introduce legislation are you happy to
get that legislation through on the back
of uh labor votes uh against some
conservative opposition and dup
opposition well look this is a high
medical situation about about having a
vote we don't we don't know what a deal
is going to look like and whether uh
whether we will need to to do that or
not
um I would hope if we arrive at a good
deal that everyone would be supporting
it but I I come back to the point Trevor
and I I'm sorry to repeat it but it is a
pretty fundamental one it doesn't really
matter what any of us in the House of
Commons think about this the deal has to
satisfy the people of Northern Ireland
okay all right
um
elsewhere Mr mclinch says that they're
going to stop the trains again the RCN
first time in its history it's going out
on the 48 hour strike without cover
Junior doctors yesterday you'd say
they're likely to come out
um is it the ministers is it Minister
Minister's position still that there's
not much you can do to stop this chaos
look I think it is political cynicism of
the worst kind to encourage strikes the
only people that benefit from strikes
are the labor party striking workers
don't benefit from strikes and uh I
think it's lunacy to
say to people the best way to help make
ends meet is to drive those ends further
apart these these are not helpful we
need to focus on issues that that each
sector is facing those are what the
respective secretaries of state are are
doing but but strikes are not helpful
and I would encourage people not to not
to do that well I can't speak for Mr
Lynch or Miss Cullen or the BMA but I
suspect if they were here they'd say
they're not much they're not very
helpful to you but they might be helpful
to these striking workers and let's so
let me ask you again
it's going to happen
is the government's view still that it
cannot play a role in avoiding these
strikes strikes are not helpful to
striking words no but that's not the
question I'm asking you as well asking
you what the government let me know what
you said because it's important striking
workers lose pay out of their pay
packets when they're on strike if their
Union demands are met with an
inflationary pay rise they lose because
that equates to about a thousand pounds
extra in tax per household and you you
it doesn't help on on the issue that
everyone is facing on inflation strikes
do not help striking workers strikes
only help the labor party and it's the
same attitude Trevor
mine is that on strike at the start of
the warmest summer on record it's the
it's the same old dogma and situation
the only thing that is going to enable
us to make progress on on the genuine
issues that certain sectors are facing
is is discussions discussions around
stresses on the NHS and all of them hang
up is what secretary you can tell them
that there's not helpful to them until
you're blue in the face but from their
point of view if they get a paywright
that is going to be helpful surely I
mean that's what that's what they're
there for not if it embeds inflation uh
no um they they are it's it's I'm sorry
but it's a it's a myth that strikes are
helpful they're not they they exacerbate
uh financial problems for the very
people going out on strike and they also
are going to have a knock-on effect on
canceled appointments on missed
education uh it's it's not good for the
country and I'd encourage people not to
do it yeah but they but they're going to
get poorer anyway because inflation
hasn't been conquered as Mr Hunt never
tires of telling us so they're getting
poorer year by year anyway let me put it
to you again is the government simply
going to sit on his hands and say
look you're chaps you're not helping
anybody you're you know it's a little
fit school teacher issue or you're
wasting your own time here I mean
honestly can ministers do nothing no the
ministers are doing a lot the you will
know that the prime minister's
priorities three of them are on are
focused on the economy including halving
uh in inflation uh that should be our
Focus that is what is going to benefit
those individuals it will benefit also
uh the the rest of the country as well
so we're very focused on this but uh
make no mistake the strikes are not
helping all right look um Mr sunak said
yesterday he wants everybody to double
down to support Ukraine
um we're not sending fighter fighter
jets despite the um clear the appeal
that Mr zlinsky
uh made uh to us are we just to be clear
we're not going to send them quite a
joke look we we've not ruled out uh
particular things and indeed the Prime
Minister has asked the defense secretary
to look at a raft of things including uh
aircraft and we are obviously providing
training support
um but the defense secretary is also
he's very focused on what is going to
help long term but also in the immediate
future and the prime minister's speech
at the security Summit in Munich was
really a a call to other nations to
recognize the critical period we are in
now in terms of Ukraine securing that
Victory that's interesting there was a
world in which penny more than might
have been the defense secretary would
the penny would penny more than his
defense secretary have wanted to send
fighter jet if we had any to spare I'm
com I'm completely in step with Ben
Wallace Ben Wallace I think has been a
fantastic defense secretary he is very
focused on giving Ukraine this support
that it needs we have led Europe in
providing that support and we're doing a
huge amount and we will continue to do
that what we have also said is we are
going to step that up in the next few
months we're going to be sending more
than we did in the entire period of last
year and and that is because we have to
bring this this war to an end we have to
help Ukraine secure that victory that is
in everyone's interest and this is a
really critical period for them to do
that there are limits to what we can do
surely
um there's a former Chief of uh actually
the chief of uh Army General
um Sir Richard Barons who says today we
need another three billion pounds we
hear that the a year to keep our status
as a leading European military power we
hear that the defense secretary wants
another 10 billion a year we understand
and that our own Munitions stocks are
being depleted because we're helping the
ukrainians
are we going to do whatever it takes
whatever it does to our own military
capacity
we know this is our first job as a
government and our record in government
has been that we have prioritized uh
defense and we have kept defense
spending strong always met our NATO
commitments but for those worried about
this I would say listen to what the
Prime Minister said in Munich listen to
what the government said in the Autumn
statement last year which recognized the
need to increase defense spending look
at what the chancellor has previously
said the son of an admiral one of the
most experienced people in cabinet about
his desire to increase defense spending
to three percent as he has made a
commitment in previous years and look at
Ben Wallace who no one can doubt his
commitment to our Armed Forces I am
confident we will keep defense spending
strong and it will be the priority for
this government okay I'm only hiring you
along because of course the big
development biggest pure political
development has been the decision of the
Scottish first minister to stand down
um
no nobody really knows the full truth of
why she's made that decision but one
element surely must have been the
decision of the Scottish secretary
Alistair Jack to block Hollywood
legislation on gender recognition
given what you yourself have said on
this issue
do you really think that Aleister Jack
was correct to do that did you support
that decision yes he was because this is
a matter not so much about the the
rights or wrongs or the merits of of
what Scotland was was trying to to do
for Trans people it was about the impact
it was having on the rest of the UK
there have been many many positive
things about Devolution but it has torn
at the social fabric of the United
Kingdom and the impact of what Scotland
was was doing on the on the workings as
you will well know at the equalities Act
was a serious problem
Scotland knew about this but everything
that you have said recently in
the past including period when you
yourself were Minister for equalities
suggests that you would have supported
the Scottish legislation no is that true
no on the issue itself I wouldn't have
because I did not wish for uh this to be
split out from health care I think this
this was a very important thing that it
remained in healthcare but what we think
about the merits of what Scotland were
trying to do is not the issue here the
reason why Aleister Jack has done what
he has done is because what Scotland was
trying to do was going to have an impact
on the workings of the equalities act
across the whole of the UK Penny Warden
thank you very much thank you
well let's get the view from labor now
with the party's Shadow Home Secretary
Yvette Cooper
good morning Shadow Home Secretary
good morning Trevor
we heard from Penny mordant if I may
start with the Nicola bully
investigation that she shared the prime
ministers and home secretaries concerns
about that investigation now you told my
colleagues here at Sky News earlier on
this week that you'd be
meeting the Lancashire police to discuss
the progress of the investigation what
what can you tell us about that
conversation
well this obviously is a very
distressing case and a family that have
a missing mum daughter wife it's a very
difficult case and my team had been in
touch with Lancashire police to have
more information but look at the heart
of this obviously the is the most
important thing is to try and find
Nicola bully in the handling of the case
obviously there was a lot of information
released and that was really unusual and
I think that's why there have been so
many concerns as a result of this but
what's happening now is the information
commissioner has said that they're going
to investigate we've also had there's
going to be further internal reviews as
well I think the right thing now is for
those to take their course and for how
to have further discussion of this in
due course but at the moment for
everyone to support the Lancashire
police investigation to try and find
Nicola and also to support Nicholas
family who who must be in the most
unimaginable Agony as a result of what's
Happening
so you still have confidence in their
handling of the matter for time being
parents and I think everybody should
support that investigation because that
has to be the priority
let's turn to the lead story of the day
I guess which is the negotiations over
the Northern Ireland protocol
um your party leader has said that if
there is a deal which is Penny mordant
said this morning is supported by all
parts of the community there then labor
would
support it if necessary vote for
Relevant legislation do uh welcome what
has been happening recently
well I hope that a deal is imminent we
have been urging the government to act
on this for a very long time we we put
forward ways and proposals as to how
that could be done so we really strongly
hope that a deal is imminent it is
strongly needed and yes as kirstama has
said we stand ready to support the
government to support Richie soon I can
getting this through will provide
political cover for him if he has
problems within his own party on this
because this is in the National interest
to get this resolved and to get this
sorted both for Northern Ireland but
also more widely for the UK
this of course is all part of Labor's
policy of trying to make brexit work now
can you imagine any deal
being acceptable to the EU that does not
involve the European court of justice
well we don't know what the discussions
are that are taking place at the moment
there is also an element already in
terms of the role that the ecj plays and
I think that seems to have become a sort
of big symbolic issue now for elements
of the conservative party the most
important thing really is to have a
practical program that works of course
they have to be dispute resolution
mechanisms as part of that but it's to
have something to work that just
simplifies the process for trade and we
believe that there are ways that could
do that what actually would be
beneficial for the whole of the UK as
well as for Northern Ireland including
we've put forward proposals around a
Veterinary agreement that would simplify
many of the checks that are in place but
as you said this is about making brexit
work this is about being very practical
it is about getting agreement and
talking to people and for a long long
time the way in which the conservatives
have handled this is just not to talk to
anybody just to get into standoffs just
to get into rhetoric rather than to
actually be really proud practical and
have a common sense approach to that
that's what we would like to see
so to be clear the involvement of the
European court of justice in for example
the settlement of uh disputes over the
details of trade would not cause labor
any any problems in supporting a deal
there's going to have to be some kind of
dispute resolution process of course
there is so we should just be really
pragmatic and common sense about
approaching that and I really really
hope that that is the approach that
ministers are taking and then they're
not going to just get all caught up in
um really the sort of the approach that
the ERG that the sections of the
conservative party have taken to this
have really got to be practical it's too
important to just end up walking away
when we need sensible measures in place
for Northern Ireland and for the United
Kingdom as a whole but that's why we
have said to Rishi sunak that if you
need support in Parliament we will be
ready to provide support in order to get
something through in the National
interest that's what it's got to be
about in the National interest not the
political rounds within the conservative
party
the political conversation is moving
rather decisively to a place in which
people are
seriously considering uh the possibility
of a labor government and um the your
leader in his speeches this week and I
guess the speech he will make today is
Scotland uh is beginning to sketch out
what labor would do so let's talk a bit
about what a labor government might look
like and talk about something very
concrete we can expect to see way with
strikes uh rail health workers teachers
and so on over the next few weeks and
months we know that the labor position
is that it would be great if the Tories
could get around the table and so on and
so forth so we don't need to go over
that
specifically
would a labor government in London make
the same offer to nurses as the labor
administrations in Scotland and Wales
are making to those workers
well we would get around the table and
negotiate where streeting has been very
clear about this from the start in fact
he's called on Steve Barkley he's called
on Richie's unit he's called on the
government to get round to the table
they really should be acting urgently
because nobody wants to see strikes
happen in the NHS least of all in fact
many of the nurses who are in such a
desperate situation they really want
something to be done so we should be
getting around to the table and
negotiating of course you don't conduct
those negotiations in public or on
television but we would be round the
table talking about paid talking about
conditions talking about the issues that
are affecting the nurses and the NHS
more widely as part of that we are also
being very clear we would increase the
training and recruitment of modern more
nurses more doctors as well and we would
cancel the unfair non-doms tax break in
order to put that money into training
the doctors and nurses we need because
if we don't get the additional Staffing
then the pressures on nurses on our NHS
staff are just going to continue and
that is really bad for patients so
without asking you so without asking you
to advance a negotiating position the
kind of deal that Scots and Scottish
Administration wealth Administration are
offering would not be off the uh out of
question for you
well I think you are actually asking me
to conduct a negotiations around the
table and yeah I think everybody has
made clear that that's not the kind of
way that you do any negotiations it's
not the way that trade unions do
negotiations either but the whole point
okay let me ask you about that you have
to get around the table and be very
sensible
all right let me ask you a specific
question about
um uh Scotland
um Your Leader has said that he would
not have supported the snp's uh gender
recognition legislation the Scottish
labor party did and whipped its msps to
vote for it
would a labor government in Westminster
faced with a Scottish labor
Administration that wanted to pass this
legislation do what the Tories have done
and block it
well the whole point when you have
conflicting legislation again is to be
able to get round a table and resolve
the issues and that's what's happened
every time in the past so there are
different issues that the Scottish
Department the Scottish government can
legislate on there are other areas where
you have uk-wide legislation so for
example the gender reassignment
legislation that is something that
Scotland can legislate on but we also
have a uk-wide equality act that's also
important and that is the area that also
protects safe spaces for example for
biological women so where you have a
potential conflict between pieces of
legislation always in the past there has
been dialogue there has been a
discussion between the Scottish
government and the UK government in
order to find a way through this is the
first time that that has always wins
doesn't it has broken down and I think
well that's partly been because I think
the the reason that's broken down is
because there's been a sort of standoff
both the smpm the conservatives haven't
wanted to have that discussion so you
have to have that discussion it may be
that you have to make changes in the law
in order to be able to accommodate it
but we think that is the approach that
you should take that is the approach
that we would take to any disagreement
with or any conflict of laws with the
Scottish Parliament okay Yvette Cooper
thank you very much for your time this
morning
thank you
you're watching Sophie Ridge on Sunday
this week with me Trevor Phillips and
still to come on the program this
morning
in just a moment I'll speak to the
former business secretary and long time
leading light of the conservative
eurosceptic right Jacob Reese mogg
and a little later we'll hear from the
former Northern Ireland secretary during
the labor government Peter now Lord
mandelson
[Music]
uh with that deal on the Northern
Ireland protocol seemingly within reach
the Prime Minister has a number of
groups to keep on side parties in
Northern Ireland of course and a little
later from here we'll hear from those
but also he has to deal with those in
his own party Who Remain deeply
skeptical of arrangements with the EU
they want the removal of the so-called
trade barrier in the IRSC and want to
ensure that the European court of
justice no longer plays a part in the
protocol
Jacob Brie smallg has long been one of
the leading lights of that wing of the
party the former business secretary
joins me now good morning mystery smog
good morning Miss Phillips
now I know we haven't seen the exact
detail yet but um
can you imagine yourself supporting any
version of a deal that has a role for
the European court of justice
well it depends very much on the
position of the dup that um under the
Good Friday Belfast agreement it set out
that there must be cross-community
consent and this requires a majority in
both communities and and the dup have
set out some very clear tests for
whether or not any agreement works and
it's much more about whether EU law
applies to what goes on in Northern
Ireland over which the people of
Northern Ireland have no say than the
European Court the European court is a
consequence of EU law taking effect in
Northern Ireland and that's the matter
that the dup has quite rightly
highlighted
so you could you can see some kind of
arrangement where for example if the EU
wants to make changes in trade
Arrangements it might consult the
Northern Ireland assembly so that the
Democratic deficit about which the dup
is concerned is to some extent remedied
the actual involvement of the EU in uh
policy and legislation is not in and of
itself a red line you're essentially
Outsourcing your judgment to the dup
e well no because the dup has set out
its requirements which I've I've got
here it's seven requirements for a new
one they've got the seven questions I
want to check on where you are choice
I I think those seven tests are
absolutely the right tests I think the
dup has set out the right test as to
whether a new agreement is in line with
the Good Friday Belfast agreement which
is a fundamental importance because
that's what's given peace to Northern
Ireland for the last 25 years and that
must underpin everything but also
whether Northern Ireland will have the
same Arrangements under article 6 of the
active Union as the rest of the United
Kingdom which has been the law of this
country since the early 19th century
where the laws in Northern Ireland
should be made by the people of Northern
Ireland or of the United Kingdom Ron
imposed upon them by the European Union
and that's what the ecga becomes a
consequence of now I think the dup's
position is extremely reasonable is why
I'm supporting it
but this will seem a little bit puzzling
if the elected government in Westminster
which is the highest Democratic
expression if I can put it that way of
the Union
decides it likes the deal it will accept
it uh it might be possible that one
party or another or some members of your
own political party don't fancy it very
much but
if you sit if you basically this is
about sovereignty if Westminster decides
this is the way to go presumably you're
you're going to say to the dup you've
got to swallow it
no that misunderstands The Good Friday
agreement that
isn't there that has led to peace as I
said for 25 years that means you need
cross-community consent and there was a
very clear promise that there would be
no change to the Constitutional
Arrangements of Northern Ireland and
without that cross-community consent and
the Northern Ireland protocol itself
says that it is subsidiary to the Good
Friday agreement so that's really very
important and this I think Alters the
tone of the question that you're asking
of course
forgive me we seem to be losing a little
bit of what
carry on do carry on
in in Northern Ireland because of the
history there is a very particular way
in which changes may be made to the
arrangements there and those have to be
followed and that's one of the seven
tests set out by the dup
but you you understand my point here
don't you that
in the end uh in our democracy
ultimately whatever an agreement that
was made in uh 25 years ago may may or
may not say whatever any individual
party thinks if Westminster decide that
is
surely the outcome of the sovereignty
for which you have argued so
vociferously vociferously if I may say
so eloquently for the last six years
Westminster decides
provide agreement which is
um co-guaranteed by the British
government
so you would be expecting his Majesty's
government to tear up something it had
already agreed to so of course there is
what it feels like but it has to
legislate within a political context of
agreements it's already made and an
agreement that is fundamental to peace
seems to me to be that the highest order
of magnitude and a government would not
want to override that Westminster would
not want to override that without going
through the proper processes and that
requires the support of the dup all
right before we move on absolutely
fundamental before we move on though I
want to talk to you about the economy
but just very quickly
um
you will probably be aware that the
former prime minister Boris Johnson has
had something to say about all of this
this morning
what's he up to
our continuing or whether we've
concluded
or if we've lost signal
do carry on I think I can still hear you
Mr E smog um I was asking you what do
you think that the former prime minister
Boris Johnson is up to it is not usual
for a former leader to intervene in this
way at such a delicate moment
I okay I regret to say we may have to
give up to uh on Mr Reese Mog on uh as
Alan Partridge used to say
on that bombshell
um
we should do is take a break and we're
back with you in a few moments
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
well we've been talking this morning
already to Penny mordant and to Yvette
Cooper the shadow home sector and we
hope to be able to talk to Peter Madison
and Naomi long in a moment but just to
remind you penny mordant and I talked at
some length about the news emerging from
the talks between the Prime Minister and
the parties in Northern Ireland and the
EU which appear
I only say appear to be heading towards
some conclusion and here's what the
leader of the House of Commons had to
say
there are encouraging signs but the
Prime Minister has said that there is
still hard work to be done and everyone
will be pulling together to ensure uh
that we're giving that deal the best
chance possible what matters here and
the prime minister is very focused on
this is what the people of Northern
Ireland think about this deal this has
to be acceptable to all communities in
Northern Ireland and the EU is aware of
that so I I wish them well I think it
would be great if we can arrive at that
point but that's the test it's not what
I or any other member of the commons
thinks it's the people of Northern
Ireland
well let's now speak to a man who knows
a thing or two about trying to strike
deals between the parties in Northern
Ireland and in Brussels I'm joined now
by the former Northern Ireland secretary
and EU trade commissioner Peter now Lord
mandelson good morning Lord mandelson
good morning
now um as an ordinalist secretary you
were responsible for implementing The
Good Friday agreement
um do you think though we don't know the
details of it but what we understand of
the rumored deal do you think that that
endanges that agreement in any way
if we get a deal over the Northern
Ireland protocol which is an essential
part of our overall uh deal with the
European Union post-brexit it will do
more than anything else to support the
Belfast Good Friday agreement it will
reinforce the peace process and help
stop any return to the violence that
we've seen in Northern Ireland in
previous decades so I'm hoping very much
indeed that the UK government and the EU
have now found a landing zone for
revising how the original Northern
Ireland protocol was operating I think
that's the important thing to achieve
and I hope very much that they're going
to be successful
in fact it did describe the protocol as
I think your words were not perfect
um does that mean that you think that it
was inadequate as a basis for agreement
or simply needed essentially some
updating some tweaking
What what is the
is it an obstacle or is it really
something that we should invest in
it was an essential thing to pre to put
in place
but the way in which it was done was not
satisfactory and the way it's operated
since has not been satisfactory I mean
Boris Johnson imposed it without
consultation with unionists and others
in Northern Ireland in the first place
he then set about uh repudiating it
having told lies about it to unionists
in Northern Northern Ireland and in the
process wrecked our partnership with the
Republic of Ireland
and did so much to destroy trust between
Britain and the European Union so I hope
he's not going to come in and start
wrecking everything all over again a
period of Silence on his part I think
would now be welcome but here's the
point Trevor
although the protocol itself is an
essential part of the overall
post-brexit deal it creates special
trading relations for Northern Ireland
which avoid uh you know a hard border
being reimposed between North and South
Island
in my view the European Union
frankly approached its implementation in
a rather clunky way I've been over
literal over overly strict and I'm glad
that the European union now has decided
to step back reconsider and approach
things in a rather more flexible way
that's what's needed now
I want to ask you about what they might
be thinking about in Brussels and moon
but if we made can I just ask you about
the dup and also about Mr Johnson's
intervention this morning uh he seems to
be saying that we should retain the
protocol bill as not as an option as a
if you like a threat to the EU penny
more than described his intervention
this morning as helpful on the ground
that it would remind the EU I guess that
this doesn't have to happen and that
they perhaps need to make more
concessions what what do you make of
that
there's nothing that Boris Johnson is
doing now or indeed throughout our
recent history with the European Union
that could possibly be described as
helpful he's wrecking he's trying to
wreck the thing because he's opposed to
the Prime Minister he wants
he and his supporters want to undermine
the Prime Minister it's just a sort of
continuation of the fratricidal war that
we see in the conservative party so I
really hope that Boris Johnson removes
himself entirely from this matter you
know we don't we don't need him wrecking
uh things uh anymore look the the point
is this that
in my view
insufficient uh attention concern was
shown by all parties the EU and the
British government towards unionist and
other sensitivities in in Northern
Ireland and they're repairing that and
that's a good thing to be doing
but it will also enable us if we get
this agreement in place to repair our
relationship between Britain and the
Republic of Ireland which is so
important in continuing to uphold the
Belfast Good Friday agreement in the
peace process but also to rebuild trust
and to reconnect Britain with the
European Union not to go back into the
European Union of course but to get a
sensible working relationship between us
you probably understand the if I can but
it's very political psychology of
Brussels and of Belfast better than
anyone else because you've had to deal
with uh both uh cities uh from the
inside the dup says in one of its seven
tests that it can't accept anything that
involves uh if you like a democratic
deficit i.eu institutions including the
ecj having a role in determining certain
kinds of policies the EU
wants uh any kind of disputes to be
settled at least in part with the
involvement of the ecj
is it conceivable that those two
mindsets can be brought together
yes it is possible and it's very
important that that that that happens
look the
arrangements are the Northern Ireland in
a sense is being given a very privileged
position to take advantage both the the
uk-wide market and economy but also the
opportunities that are offered by a
special association with Europe's single
Market
that's going to be very important by the
way for Northern Ireland's economic uh
future there are real advantages real
opportunities now available to Northern
Ireland and I'd like to you know see
those properly uh realized but I would
just make two points about this
whilst the rules of the single Market
will apply however flexibly and and uh
uh and and wisely
um there there will be occasions when
some arbitration is needed and that's
why the role of the European Court comes
into play but I hope that that the court
and its role will be downplayed I hope
the European Court takes a very clear
back seat in the operation of these
Arrangements but secondly and I said
this to former colleagues of mine in the
European commission Before Christmas it
would be a very good idea if the
European Union in its approach to
Northern Ireland it consults not just
the unionists but all the parties the
Northern Ireland assembly as a whole
in it how it goes about uh operating
these arrangements and if they've got to
be adjusted or changed in the future
then consult people talk to people and I
think the European Union are now mindful
of the need to do that and I very much
hope they'll do so in the future
to talk to you about the other big
political development or another big
political development of the week and
that is the uh announced resignation of
Scotland's first Minister Nicola
sturgeon
so it's goodbye Nicola good news for
labor
I think it is good news for labor but
you know what's more important for labor
and its electoral prospects is not what
happens to Nicholas sturgeon but but how
the changes that have been brought about
in the labor party by kirstalmers
leadership are embraced by the UK
electorate as a whole the changes in the
labor party are much more important to
our electoral prospects than what's
going on in the SNP
but of course it opens up an opportunity
for us in Scotland we badly need to win
back seats we've got a superb leader of
Scottish labor and Asawa who works very
very closely with Kia stammer and I
think that the opportunity now is for
labor not to offer a different version
of nationalism to the Scottish people
but an alternative to nationalism what
the labor party will do for the Scottish
economy and jobs and skills the Health
Service and Health Care delivery
transport education fighting crime yes
these are the big issues now on which
the next election is going to be fought
I want to come to one of those big
issues in a moment but just very um
uh quickly on the politics of this you
talked about the changes in labor the
equality and Human Rights Commission
this week uh said that labor was in
effect out of special measures on the
question of anti-Semitism and the leader
has basically has said that Jeremy
corbyn will not be a labor candidate
um now there's some question about
whether he can actually guarantee that
but
um is that the right decision or is it
just a provocation yes it is that it is
the right decision look it's also
inevitable I mean Jeremy corbyn who
played such a part and was so
instrumental in uh in tolerating
anti-Semitism in the labor party so much
for part of the problem it has chosen
himself not to be part of the solution
and therefore I think his withdrawal is
inevitable
one very last brief question if I may um
leg party today is talking about uh a
new regime on the anti-social Behavior
Uh cracking down on people who are
repeatedly disrupting Town centers and
so on
um it struck me reading their release
there was quite an echo of uh something
that was uh said during your time in
government to be tough on crime
um I look back to so see Jack Straw's
comments about getting Winos and
squeegee Merchants off the street
um
Back to the Future but maybe back to New
labor
now I think what's important is that the
the current leadership and Shadow
cabinet front bench of the labor party
look look at all that we did as a
government learn all the lessons and
then see seeing the new challenges uh
that the country faces some of which are
similar some of which are new
you know take what we did forward adapt
it build on it I mean apply it to the
second century second decade of the 21st
century I mean nobody wants to have
turned the clock back but I think that
you know what you're seeing in the labor
party leadership now you know it's a lot
of sense a lot of practicality kirstalm
has made it absolutely clear that he
wants to fight the next election on the
center ground of British politics okay
and I think that uh you know strong
modern center-left policies are what a
are required by the country now no
equally there's a fringe in the labor
party that wants to contest that
um my view is that the labor party can't
make two offers at the next election it
has to be a starma offer and not a sort
of Corp in tinged uh offer and I think
if those people in the labor party can't
get behind starma then they should be
the ones who step back
Lord mantelson thank you so much for
your time this morning pleasure
the hardest task in getting a deal
across the line in Northern Ireland will
of course be getting the different
communities and parties to agree and
then to get back to the Stormont
assembly
the toughest nut to crack in this is the
leading unionist party the dup which
says there must be fundamental change
and they won't rejoin power sharing
until their requirements are met
other parties have been deeply critical
of that approach across Community
Alliance party amongst them and its
leader Naomi long joins me now live from
Belfast
good morning Miss Long
good morning
now you met with the Prime Minister uh
this week despite the fact that I got
they sent the your invitation to the
wrong place uh you did eventually manage
to get together
um did you come away from that thinking
that a deal could be done
well I mean I think the Prime Minister
certainly was reassuring in the sense
that he was speaking positively
um about tidy negotiations were going
but he was also realistic about the fact
that there was a lot of work to do and
in Northern Ireland we perhaps better
than anywhere else understand that you
could be 95 of the way to a deal but
it's the last five percent that is often
the hardest bit to finish so near but
it's still very far I think on teledeal
is over the line until it's agreed we we
really won't know
um the final outcome but from our
perspective we wanted to communicate to
the Prime Minister the importance of
listening to all of the parties in
Northern Ireland and recognizing that
over 70 percent of people in Northern
Ireland support
um remaining within the single Market
want to have dual Market access and that
that is the bottom line irrespective of
the dep's tests that is the bottom line
for the majority of people in Northern
Ireland
in that final five percent that you
referred to
who and what is in that box do you think
who what where are the final obstacles
well I mean I think that there are some
of the issues I mean I was listening to
Lord mandelson and I think he very
clearly said I for example the issue
around a democratic deficit the need for
the EU to engage with Northern Ireland
parties I have to say the EU have been
very willing to do that in fact they
wanted to set up a new office in Belfast
where they could do that and it was the
British government that stood in the way
I thought and objected so I hope that
that will be dealt with as part of the
discussions but also I think issues
around for example the jurisdiction
um of the European court of justice is
likely to be one of the sticking points
in order to remain part of the single
Market there are certain things that we
have to adapt to in Northern Ireland one
of those is around where the final Point
um of decision making on disputes will
be I mean this is a fairly um high level
discussion unionism treated as though it
is a constitutional issue I think most
businesses I think most people
um treat it as though it is a pragmatic
um a pragmatic solution to a problem
that needs to be resolved if there are
disputes trade disputes or other
disputes between Northern Ireland
companies and those in the rest of the
EU there has to be a court that has
jurisdiction in both in order to be able
to resolve those but I'm a pragmatist in
this if the EU can find a solution to
this intractable problem along with the
UK government then I think that's
something we would all welcome but I
wouldn't want it to be blown out of
proportion the reality here is that no
business in Northern Ireland has been
coming to me in a cold sweat worried
about the jurisdiction of the ecj what
they're worried about is their ability
to continue to trade into both markets
and then to exploit that dual Market
access in order to grow our economy and
bring prosperity to the people of
Northern and Ireland is your is it your
point that um
an economic or trade problem and a
practical problem is being turned into a
constitutional issue and doesn't need to
um I know that you told my colleague
Sophie Ridge on this program previously
that the dup are holding the people of
Northern Ireland to Ransom is that what
you mean
well I mean both I think first of all
these are not constitutional issues and
the Good Friday agreement was set out
very clearly High the Constitutional
possession of Northern Ireland would be
changed it would only be with the
express consent and will of those who
live here and that has not happened
there has been no referendum on that so
we remain part of the United Kingdom and
unionism should be secure in that I
think in terms of holding the holding
the people of Northern Ireland to Ransom
absolutely that is the case the dup
walked away from functioning
institutions they have left us without a
government and now without ministers and
so we are in a relationship essentially
on pretty choppy Waters when it comes to
the economic and financial situation
facing Northern Ireland so I mean this
we have no we have no leverage if you
like in the debate with the EU and the
UK other than the persuasiveness of our
argument but I think it's wrong to
collapse the institutions there is no
good reason why we could not have
functioning institutions and as an
executive collectively speak to the UK
government about what the majority of
people in Northern Ireland want about
the concerns we have around the
heavy-handed bureaucracy of the protocol
and at the same time be able to move
forward with the pragmatic politics that
needs to be done in terms of reforming
our Health Service delivering education
and improving our justice system
well in a way that takes us takes me on
to an underlying question I I wanted to
ask you to address the
Arrangements uh for democracy in
Northern Ireland are really ruled by The
Good Friday agreement now we've had two
lengthy periods where essentially there
has been no devolved government one
because Sinn Fein wouldn't sit once
because the dup won't sit but though
they're able to achieve that outcome
because of those arrangements under the
Good Friday agreement is it your view
that at some point soon
we're all going to have to reconsider
whether that is the best way to Run
Northern Ireland's Administration
well I think that the principles of the
Good Friday agreement of inclusion um of
equality and a fairness of working
together is the right and is are still
the right principles and have stood the
test at the time over the last 25 years
however I think that the as it's been
described the ugly architecture of our
structures and institutions here which
have embedded sectarianism and Division
I think do need to be reviewed my own
party's growth is evidence that this is
not a binary Community you're not either
unionist or nationalist there are lots
of people who are unionist nationalists
and many other things as well so from
our perspective we think that a review
of The Good Friday agreement structures
is long overdue we need to do that in
order to ensure that we have stable
government you've referred to two
lengthy periods um of suspension we've
actually had now three lengthy periods
of suspension plus a number of other
very unstable periods in the last 25
years and I think when something isn't
delivering what it said it would in
strong one paragraph one which was
stable devolved government for Northern
Ireland then we have to go back to the
drawing board with the institutions and
look at what can be improved we have put
forward fairly modest proposals in terms
of how those structures could work
better in order that parties could be
still based on their mandate part of
government but if they choose to opt out
they can't prevent government continuing
and I think very few would opt out if
they thought government would go on
without them they opt out because they
know that it brings everything to Halt
and I think the government irrespective
of whether a deal is able to be achieved
with the EU that satisfies the dup's
current demands I think the government
needs to do that reform of the
institutions because inevitably there
will be other political problems that
emerge down the line which to
destabilize it in the future okay Naomi
long thank you so much I know that we'll
return to that in due course but thank
you
thank you
now just before we go a quick reminder
of our weekly podcast if you scan the QR
code on your screen right now you can
find the Sophie Ridge on Sunday podcast
And subscribe so it's in your feed each
week
I'll be joined today by Alex Brown of
the Scotsman and as usual by our editor
Scott Beasley and you can find it and
subscribe wherever you get your podcast
just search for Sophie Ridge on Sunday
that's it for this week's Sophie Ridge
on Sunday normal service resumed next
week in a moment after the break we'll
run through today's interviews and see
what we learned I'll be joined by the
journalist Anna mciliver and John
Stevens thanks for joining me this
morning
foreign
[Music]
that we educate young people to
understand about their fertility I mean
I think we tend to focus on sex
education as how to prevent a pregnancy
I think they also need to know that
fertility is finite that there will come
a time when it's not going to be quite
so easy to have children if that's what
they choose to do
and there's an inevitability about you
know understanding about periods and the
fact that some women you know most women
with an inevitability that women are
going to become menopausal when they get
to a certain age so I think it's really
about allowing ensuring that women have
got the tools they need to be able to
fulfill their fertility I often say you
know we need to make sure that every
girl and woman in this country can make
her own decision about if and when and
with whom and how many times she becomes
pregnant if she wants to I'll say a
little bit of personal experience I was
34 when I started trying to conceive I
thought it was the perfect age
um I think that you know that was
certainly what I was told in school you
know focus on going to University
getting a career and after a year of
trying to conceive my partner and I were
diagnosed with unexplained infertility
and that was the start of a decade-long
struggle to conceive that involved a
total of 11 rounds of IVF so yes I'm
very much with Leslie that we need to
teach young people how not just how not
to get pregnant but also how to get
pregnant you can get pregnant in your
30s we're not saying that at all but it
does get harder the older you get
because you're born with your lifetime
supply of eggs and they diminish and I
also think it's really important to
recognize that there are many routes to
Parenthood and reproductive science has
helped that and there are ways of
getting pregnant older you know through
things like egg donation or surrogacy
but I think what's really really
important is that people understand
all the financial implications the
ethical implications the health
implications of those different routes
to Parenthood so that's why it's so
important that this education happens
when you're young so that you know what
all the options are to starting a family
because we know that family is so
important to people and that they have
their they have the opportunity to
choose what is right for them and know
all the implications of those
foreign
[Music]
files
welcome back we're going to take a trot
through our interviews this morning now
and joining me are the deputy political
editor of the mail on Sunday Anna
mciliver and a political editor of the
Daily Mirror
um let me start with you Anna uh good
morning both of you but um Anna what
what stood out for you this morning from
what you heard
I think the reaction to Boris Johnson's
interventions were the most uh um
interesting we got we had Penny Morden
being desperate to paint it as helpful
which is in slight contrast to
government sources anonymously telling
everyone that he's a bloody nuisance
this morning
um and also the the Evergreen quote from
Penny uh more than saying but it's just
Boris being Boris which I think you
could probably apply to quite a few of
the former prime minister's actions uh
so there's that and then and then
similarly Peter mandelson I thought
again weighing in from a different point
of view on on Johnson's comments saying
that a period of Silence would now be
welcome I think a lot of people would
say the same about Lord mandelson
uh it's interesting isn't it uh these
you you can't keep these guys down can
you I mean Johnson and indeed mandelson
uh they're going to be in our headlines
forever it seems
yeah and I think Boston's knew exactly
what he was doing this weekend there's
been a vacuum because these negotiations
are going on behind the scenes number 10
have been very desperate not to kind of
give a running commentary when Rishi
sooner was out yesterday at the Munich
security conference he didn't really
give much away they want all these
things to be dealt with behind the
scenes kind of tee up the DP get their
ERG people on side make sure that
negotiations are progressing through
they don't really want to have these
wells in public and Boris Johnson
clearly knew that the news gender
constantly needs feeding he's got all
these Sunday newspapers he needed to
write something about the brexit
negotiations and he was quite happy to
throw this grenade in there put this
Source quote out there saying that if
Richard sunat gets rid of the Northern
Ireland protocol bill this bit of brexit
legislation that he started going
through Parliament then that would be a
mistake and he got the result he wanted
he's on the front page of several
newspapers
we're talking about him on your program
today and it's boarded on some front and
center again exactly where he likes to
be but it's quickly both of you I mean
other other than sort of attention you
know any showman wants that what is a
possible political game for him in this
Anna
well of course the the endless talk of
Boris Johnson possible comeback if
Richie soon act does
um badly in the local elections his
allies have been quietly talking about a
possible return uh this year
um by the end of this year if
um uh if if things continue to
to not improve in the polls for Rishi
sunak uh and then and then it's the
other argument which is it might just be
cynical uh try to keep not only his name
in the paper as John says but trying to
keep his pay packet up
um and keep himself relevant with the uh
very big paychecks he's getting for
speeches and his post Prime ministerial
life so that's also part of the game for
former Prime Ministers you do want to
have things to talk about so that you
can also continue to rake in millions on
the side all right well let's not um get
too obsessed by Boris Johnson's wallet
let's uh deal as we do in this program
with matters of substance and the
efforts to break the ampass over
post-brexit training Arrangement
um Penny Morden told us she's focused on
what the people of Northern Ireland want
there are encouraging signs but the
Prime Minister has said that there is
still hard work to be done and everyone
will be pulling together to ensure uh
that we're giving that deal the best
chance possible what matters here and
the prime minister is very focused on
this is what the people of Northern
Ireland think about this deal this has
to be acceptable to all communities in
Northern Ireland and the EU is aware of
that so I I wish them well I think it
would be great if we can arrive at that
point but that's the test it's not what
I or any other member of the commons
thinks it's the people of Northern
Ireland
John um Penny Morton was
I think we used to use the word delphic
I.E
couldn't really work out where she was
on it now is that do you think because
um they don't know how it's going to
work out or whether it's going to work
out or
Richardson does but Penny Morton doesn't
or they really aren't confident that
they've got a deal what what do you
think is going on here
I mean I think it's a bit of both really
I mean Penny Moore's it clearly isn't in
the heart of these negotiations she's
the commons leader so it will be her
role to kind of set aside government
time in the Commons to get this through
work out how do you do it do you have a
vote as you manage to get it through in
secondary legislation without MPS having
a proper vote that's kind of her domain
and I thought she was quite interesting
on that she said it's not clear that
they will need to have a vote when she
was talking to you but yeah on the
actual details of where exactly we are
in negotiations she's clearly not at the
heart of those negotiations and perhaps
because she knew she was coming on the
Sunday program she decided that it's
probably better not to know the details
and come out blind and do you agree with
that and or did you get any more than
John or I got from her
absolutely right she's she sort of
setting the scene as well for what would
be the next battle which is in the
Commons so trying to make it clear that
it's not it's bigger than any one Member
of Parliament that of course uh will
send or try to send a signal to members
of the European research group who are
already have been coming out
um and and laying down red lines David
Jones has been making quite despite also
not having any knowledge of actual
negotiations making it clear that there
are certain things about the role the
ecj that you just would not find
acceptable so the government is
obviously looking ahead assuming a deal
can be brought over the line within days
and uh saying you know what where the
next battle lies even if there isn't a
vote there'll still be a debate and
opposition from probably within its own
ranks okay I I did say we wouldn't get
obsessed by Boris Johnson's um wallet
but the truth is uh we did start talking
about his intervention uh on the
Northern Ireland protocol negotiations
and it's clear that already it's
threatening to cause a potential Tory
Rebellion uh now Penny Morton said the
the former prime minister should be
heard
Boris is is being Boris but I wouldn't
say this is this is a completely
unhelpful uh intervention
um and I think as I say the Prime
Minister uh I think will acknowledge
that uh having the Northern Ireland
protocol Bill there having the the work
uh that the former prime minister did is
has helped us get where we are but it's
always been our preference to try and
have a negotiated settlement and and
that is what everyone is working to
there's still a lot to be done or
progress has been made
John John the moments as an interviewer
where you're saying opposite somebody
and you know you think in your head I
know she's got to say this but does she
really believe that anybody really
believes it when she says this is
possibly helpful
yeah I mean I think that was a generous
interpretation on Penny morden's behalf
and I think possibly she just didn't
want to inflame the Tory brexit War she
didn't want to say anything that kind of
made Boris Johnson come out and make
further remarks but I think she did have
a point on what matters here is what
people of Northern Ireland think about
this because the key thing that this uh
deal has to achieve is getting this
storm on assembly back up running we
know that they haven't had one for
several months now the dep are refusing
to go back into a power sharing
Arrangement so yeah you can get a deal
with the EU you can get it through the
commons but if the dups still won't go
back into that power sharing agreement
then it's kind of pointless and that is
going to have to be the big test where
she's doing that does he manage to
negotiate something that the dep is
willing to accept
agree that in the sense of dup
exercise of veto
well yeah once again dp's role is
absolutely Center Stage I think what
we're seeing here is quite a
uncharacteristically for British Unix
Premiership strategy so far I mean he is
taking a big risk here by by
um trying to get this all over the line
and and showcasing it going out
personally so it'll be interesting to
see how it plays out because there are
quite a few hurdles yet uh yet to
overcome
well no no there's a big story if it's
not the only one in town penny more than
had some interesting marks on the
continuing campaign of strikes saying
industrial action does nothing to help
working people
I think it is political cynicism of the
worst kind to encourage strikes the only
people that benefit from strikes are the
labor party striking workers don't
benefit from strikes and I think it's
lunacy to say to people the best way to
help make ends meet is to drive those
ends further apart
and there's a long history about
industrial relations isn't there that um
the public tends to stand off a bit and
blame militant unions and so on so forth
but as they go on uh the tendency has
been for government to end up being
blamed do you think that the government
is playing this right by essentially
saying nothing to do with us really
well it's part of the same old narrative
I mean she once again uh said that the
pay rise would be inflationary and she
like in the clip we just heard
made a real effort to pin this back at
Labor's front door so just said it
starts to start stirring
um uh in in fighting and the confusion
within Labor's ranks over over strikes
But ultimately as you say I mean
the strikes have to be seen in the
current context of double-digit
inflation and I think that is where what
we've seen is a different level of
public perception to them as even you
say um we've seen historically a lot of
people as Apollo shows have actually
been on the side of striking workers
particularly in the Health Service and I
think that is where you know
um Penny wardens as you called it school
teacher-ish school teacher cherish
um approach today doesn't quite land
just saying to people oh this isn't
going to work stop doing it it does not
seem to be a particularly viable
negotiating strategy
yes I I have to say John I I now
slightly look back and say did I
actually say to her you're talking so
you're saying to Mick Lynch you're
wasting your own time but anyway
um your paper's been very vociferously
in support of particularly the Health
Service workers
um if you had to take a bet uh is the
government's sort of view that in the
end people will come to see it their way
do you think that's a reasonable bet
I think the government is miscalculated
the strikes right from the beginning you
know at the start they thought that this
was when it was just a whale sharks they
thought this was a tour they could be
kissed armor with and say Labor's on the
side of the strikers but we know that
the strikes have spread from sector to
sector you know they're now affecting
ambulances civil servants teachers we're
not talking about hundreds of thousands
of people getting caught up in these
strikes and I think the government's
attitude at first was that they weren't
going to get round the table with unions
that this was for kind of NHS bosses to
deal with rather than ministers then
after the new year they back down on
that they have had some meetings with
union leaders but if you look at the
polling there is still strong support
for the strikers particularly as you
mentioned those in the Health Service
and I think that you know we get this
continuing people can't get appointments
at hospitals they're struggling to get
ambulances I think people will continue
to question what Earth our ministers
going to do to actually sort this out
and I think penny more than coming out
on TV and saying oh if you go on strike
that's not particularly helpful for you
it's only helpful for labor as Anna says
I think most people will just look at
that it doesn't quite land as an
argument I think it's just a
continuation of the government
misjudging this kind of attitude okay um
but before we go we've only got a minute
so left
um you know all of this is fascinating
to us politics nerds but I think for
most or much of the country anyway there
is in a way more a bigger or at least a
more affecting story going on and that
is the investigation Into The
Disappearance of Nicola bully um and I
know your papers really pursued this
what did you make of what Yvette Cooper
had to say about
her encounter with Lancashire police
where essentially she said we let them
do their job
she did but she also repeated her
earlier critical comments which was
um that the releasing of private
information about Nicola bullet was
unusual as she put it which is obviously
by euphemism there
um today I mean there's so many uh
people coming out criticizing this from
the police
okay I'm so sorry I've got to stop you
there but um thank you both very much
that is it from Sophie Ridge uh on
Sunday and the take this morning next
week it's civilized against Sophie's
back
[Music]